Identification.
This is station twelve with faith bend
and Karen Craig recorded on Friday sixteenth of August one thousand nine hundred seven tape begins in a few seconds.
And if identification.
If you're going to talk about Tran be shortly after the family should push forward we're holding a meeting rooms of the
fellowship of Australian writers. Which were in Clarence street. Fascinating. Portraits of.
A couple of famous writers like looked at him. I think it was the other a photograph or. I'm not quite sure.
And people of that time. It was a lovely place to me it was very central. And at that meeting your father played.
And he was an Anglican priest very excited about the formation of the fellowship because he really wanted to get away
from charities and you know a very political elf very political. And he wanted to. Get Hawaii from.
What the churches had been doing up to date. Brainwashing children and.
And also could see that was need for an organisation that had Aboriginal people in the leadership and.
So he came in and we met. Now this could have been the beginning of fifty.
And he introduced himself to me and he said we have to get together and I think that's a good idea
but I was rather shy about getting together with the past and I've had enough of a charity. And they ruthless.
People who are concerned. That they did what they believed was the right thing to do at the time and of course.
Picked up whatever social services they could for those children and used. At their own discretion.
And with the color of their money. I was a bit wary about this.
But it belonged to the Anglican Church and where other people who belong to the Anglican Church.
Getting together are not overly interested and well. Shortly after that rang me up and I thought about you know.
He belonged to a Union WU. But he was no priest for that.
He was out at that time to get co-operative for Aboriginal people
and by then he already had one established out in the north Queensland shortly after that I think it was he established
another one which is on the north coast of Yousef wilds. And he saw a car getting into the problem.
That Aboriginal people were confronted with. I think it sounds nice guy. So I said. Well it's like this.
I've got a little and it's difficult for me to get into. Would you like to come to dinner.
And he said yes he would Can I bring up my tiny kitchen. And those days you know. Do you know mainly working.
And I think for many many people it would come to work out some political issue.
And that black would have a chop and that would be. If you had to pay to you know you would do well. And why.
But we set a date and. And he brought someone who was the treasurer for the co-op. And he came and he had her back.
Well we couldn't believe it was true.
It was just one more so then and Australians were really you know one hundred at that.
But we got in the little kitchen it chops and drank that one. And then I said Well.
It was possible that there would be a place. To the co-op.
Training College a place for a training college
and then was preparing to follow the launch of the foundations of the college. I shan't go into great detail so.
The beginning of this college train the I will have to check up with one of the founding members who is far more
involved.
But somehow I went along to the founding of Trampy which was held in the whole of the Anglican Church
and the Town Hall is I think the interests. Center interests. So we went along. You know all us heathens.
And said yeah.
All of fellowship executive for there
and I was talking with someone you know from before the meeting actually opened
and our secretary of the Fellowship secretary said Come on fights way fellowship a formal sit together case is a vote
and when all of the same why is this lovely.
When I could remember quite a few passages from a couple of politicians like a politician.
And that was the beginning of Trinity. Now. ELPH was a person who very rigidly opposed.
Anything that put this politically.
And so he wouldn't take a grant from the federal government from the state government.
Well I said to him to get the bloody money from. You bring students into this house.
You've got to feed them make sure they are washed and they were washing is dumb. What kind of thing you did mummy.
He said. We'll get it. We'll get it now I want you to fight to organize it.
And I'll get permission and one how did they only pointer headed.
And I could see that he wanted to get me involved in getting this college. Absolutely absolutely.
But I said I'll tell you what. I'll give you a hand to turn a dinner on.
By invitation and we'll charge people five pounds.
That's a good idea and we'll try and get everything then I hated I said
when you arrived in bases I don't know what would refer.
He went down to fish markets and told them they had to do you see today. And what have you. He went to the.
What was the hotel club and restaurant Union. And said to Harry. They can have to check that. It was a share.
And he said Look fundraiser. Trampy Will you come with me. Of course. Danny hadn't seen the kitchen in this. Kitchen.
And we had to we had to put it back. So that it wouldn't put the gas.
Well we had this and it fell fast always from the union. To Trampy and all his life going. Labor party night.
Well by the time they all coughed up their five pounds each. We made a good cop. And I come to see.
Well day after to recess and what about the fight.
I said Now I'll know why but they forced it didn't turn out that way he hadn't very winning way about him
and I found myself to gather with three fellowship women. Yes Rigby the wife of a parliamentarian state. And myself.
They are on the streets trying to sell these old. And I thought.
Look I've got to learn how to say no I'm not for this White. So we made a car.
But when that was all suggested we should have another one and sell it to some of the stalls.
So you got someone to do that.
But I was very involved in tramp he in those first few years very involved in raising funds.
And if he whoever was the manager wanted to die off on Saturday to go to the races or have a fling at Taboo. You know.
I'd go over and cook for the day and look after who were there at the place it was very quite dilapidated thing.
There were some strange happenings.
Like I had very good teachers that and one morning lecture time there was a student missing.
So I went in and I said I happened to be there that day into his office and I said Look.
So it hasn't turned out that he's a boda hero he's a live. STUDENT.
Oh well they're all led out people didn't like to intrude into the bedrooms very quickly.
And they were sent to invade with. The students come from. Where did the Kurdish draw them. Drew them from the island.
It will always include. Chang The last prime minister of PE and she was a student there for a while.
And the priest John my mouse who was I think a member of Parliament for one of the places electorates. Adjourning.
My mouse my mouse I think it is was a student of training base out had these contacts. And we had one today.
Long before there was a Fijian migration to Australia and. They came from the tourist trade.
The two people who came from the tourist trade.
Took very good courses and saw them through one for butchery and the other for bankers.
And he was turned out to be a very good buy. And I came from Queensland.
So the origins of trendy were not really a cultural truly multicultural truly multicultural indeed.
Now I'll just come back to the man who did it because he was such a success.
The waterside workers raised the money to get has been established at Tara Strait Islands.
So you'd like to think it was functioning with that any government sources and
and what else would do you in the afternoon before five o'clock you do the rounds of the pub where all the union
leaders drink. And then you just love to.
And the general secretary telling it to me one face for twenty thousand dollars pounds I think it was.
Give it all to our fellowship. And the right. Morale and unity between the fellowship and trembly.
Not coming back to try and be another. It had a wonderful beginning break. Having a coffee now. Sorry Carol. OK.
Well in the early years of travel. I guess I became quite a big part of it. And. We drew other people.
But in those days. Crates of. And trendy was a place where the matter of what you.
Emerged as a problem or anything else. But you see. Now I remember I was cooking over there.
I told At The Races on the Saturday.
Well I didn't go to the races but he arrived back and he had the Federal Member for Bruce Manfred cross. To see to.
He had a senator. Who was very involved in the rights of people. And.
Who I think he was actually one of the directors of trampy and did we exploited him. And his name was Bill Rigby here.
Now. The four of them came in. And the head fit brought beer and stuff. And I can recall.
Potatoes in camp and I got stuck into it. Of all places in the church.
I think I mentioned earlier but you see train we had a chapel and by having the chapel they didn't have to pay right.
Well one of the talks about politics and what have you and it was teeming with rain and the rain was coming in
and I was running around. Dishes to catch the droppings. The place wasn't flooded. They always given me.
Was a great spirit. It was tough. It was.
You know there was never any money if you work for train but you work because you believed it.
And the only person who was paid. I think Secretary who lived here. But like the other.
The money raised from the union. And that my family went for the teachers. It was a place of great gathering.
You could always rely on a great welcome overseas. Trampy Trampy would welcome people who have.
Elf was a great leader for people. One couldn't help but harden our spirit. Because he was out. He was totally without.
He believed that we should work together for the good of the people. Our place became a bit of a gathering place.
And I want to true in the fight. We had a way to have one roof. We had done my. Co-op. What to call it.
Anyhow he was very dedicated to the rights of the rich and you went to jail went to jail with.
Dollars over here for a big meeting we're having in that little room we had that was from the waist.
The street from the world. And I am through probably from Sydney University who was. And with comparison. Of.
I lay that out. And now. Harold come up from. Oh yes. Now what. The author and poet. Who wrote Quincy and.
Dorothy Hewett
and Dorothy had come mainly because of dogs because Dorothy was very involved in that great struggle for a decent way
of the pastoral work. That was. And it was the stranger's assembly of people.
And then it was all said Diagne he was a Christian church pastor. And he'd come up from Mount.
But he didn't want to sit in the same room as the street because he said she was a communist what. Quick smart.
Trade we had a great collection of people from different walks of life
and most people who were there were there because of. Where we built our house the trenches.
There were people like Jesse and of who shed crocodile tears because it was too inconvenient to get up different.
Like it was just happens from the city on her tray and your room in our flat
and many a thing was cooked up in that flat I can tell you many things. And when. French's forest.
They weren't overly happy about that but it didn't take long to find someone who became a regular show for
and this was a bloke who had to look at tests and they are not the only way to this.
And it was why I'm wonderful cheeses. So I offered often get this. To drive him first to the shop.
So it make a few donations like cheese and grog and braid bread
and then he will go on to French's forest around through the spade two and three in the morning
when I'd be throwing these blokes. Would have to go to work. You see.
If you try and be through some extraordinary people. And I'd like to talk about some of the writers. One day.
We had already moved to forest and it may have been around nineteen fifty eight.
I think that my friend rang me up and she said come down. The someone coming here might like you to meet.
And I said All right a high point. And there was a tiny little woman who had an extraordinary.
It was plastered in the place for far and almost like a cross.
Too big for this tiny little figure I thought and she was wearing a red and white striped cotton frock.
Tiny little white you know we all had Carolyn Martin gone by the way. But he how she was and it happened.
And we were sitting down having one of us. Lunch is usually little bits and pieces brought in from the brain.
What have you got. Do you mean you say you know I started telling the stories about my childhood.
Going to school on what it was like during the Depression in a country. And faith you have to write it.
And it was like saying to me this bottle of whiskey polish it off or you know or whatever I could never write.
I thought so I said Oh yes yes she says you have to write it and it was there backing her out.
And she says that wonderful stories for if you really got to put it down. They were wonderful those two women to me.
Then you finished that. And then badgering me and said look I'm such and such a night.
I'm going to visit a friend who lives up on the Hill right. There appealing.
And we had a lot of friends looking up on the very plateau. And I noticed the Ridge Hill because they were all lefty.
You know the way. And they're sure the bra. All living up there and they most of it built their own houses on the tree.
But she was taking me to a man by the name of Joe. And beautiful overlooking. Absolutely beautiful. George still very.
And he produced. Had a beautiful grand piano.
And what had happened to his wife had left him with a child and he was bringing that child up himself.
And when we'd have supper he'd take him to the little boy. And he was very proud to be bringing that child.
So we were sitting at the supper table.
With a lot of hunger and bread and sauerkraut what have you and I was telling you the story.
I think I've always I think I've already mentioned to you about having to do the family which was in primary school.
And the sole of my shoe was coming off of my school shoe. And my mother. That night and back on with.
And very thick straighten and then she put a black shoe polish to the string so that I get could.
Have turned ON THE STORY. Expensive. Now over the salami and playing in the back.
And I can remember that he the old record he would always play.
In the times I went after that first meeting and they'd Africa very famous. Soprano. He didn't like her.
You know another one but it was to be sung on the water. Float just Absolutely. So. He said to me you must write it.
You faith and when you write it. I'm telling you. Michael that one day you are going to be a great leader.
And you will write books.
But begin by writing those stories and he had a will of you and you know if he said something he wanted one.
To take notes. Didn't mean a thing to me. I used to let those things just go out the window thinking me right.
You know. But I shall always place because she made sure.
That I would have contacts with people who were prepared to listen and give me.
Encouragement and this terrible which I had started. And the writer on a national level.
Decided that they would have a conference here in Sydney. And it was held in a house in Castle Craig. And I said to my.
Look do you think it would help pay for food. Because you're going to going to be fed.
In the house and she said Oh yes said to be wonderful and I can remember making this.
And taking it to this conference of Australia and right there. You know. De Blasio.
Who had just published the book Graham and Coca-Cola my. You must read some of his work. Sometime.
And Stephen Mary Smith who was about to get off the ground.
John Manno for whom I had already made I meet John in nine hundred forty nine in Melbourne.
And I thought he was beautiful
and lovely just that was at the International Peace Congress now John was an extraordinary person
and died before his time.
But Hanson I became very close friends with John and Katie never manifolds the early settlers in Victoria.
You might recall how they built the Bluestone castle. They were scores of people but they were Melbourne people.
And he became his uncle. So chased him and became very famous with race horses.
Well the race is that very upper crust theory upper crust. But OK.